[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
opening statements in the so-called
daytona beach serial killer trial mr
robert hayes is guilty to be on a
reasonable doubt
of killing
not once not twice
but three times plus eight years after a
deadly shooting at a florida movie
theater opening statements are set to be
presented and the death of amir lock our
son died
by the hands of minneapolis
a trigger happy minneapolis police
officer how locke's family is seeking
justice but first state wisconsin versus
daryl brooks the deadly waukesha holiday
parade what plea accused daryl brooks
enters law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian bockmeyer along with terry
austin the man accused of killing six
people and injuring dozens more in the
waukesha holiday parade pleads not
guilty to more than 70 charges accused
daryl brooks jr appeared in waukesha
county court on friday for his
arraignment
last november prosecutors say
39-year-old brooks drove his vehicle
through a crowded holiday parade killing
six people and injuring dozens more he
now faces 77 total charges including six
counts of homicide and multiple counts
of reckless endangerment in a brief
court appearance on friday the court
commissioner announced a new judge will
be appointed to the case brooks's
defense team also entered a plea on
behalf of their clients
good morning mr brooks we are here on
your
arraignment date
uploaded into the file yesterday i
believe it was was a motion for
substitution of judge that is timely
filed and
already the
matter has been reassigned to judge doro
and so let me turn to attorney kerry
attorney perry
will mr brooks acknowledge that he has
received a copy of the information and
will he leave its reading yes we've
received a copy of the information we'd
waive formal reading and we can enter
please if not guilty this morning
brooks's attorney has filed for a change
of venue motion due to national media
attention the case has received brooks
is set to appear in court next month
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney matthew mangino and terry
austin matthew as we learned more and
more about bricks junior's criminal
history how does that affect the
investigation into why his bill was so
low
well brian it's really interesting uh
you know as i understand it he had a
50-page ratchet
which means he had a series of charges
and convictions over an extended period
of time
uh you know when you consider bell
you look at two different things you
know one is this person likely to evade
further hearings and leave the
jurisdiction not be available for trial
and number two is is he a safety risk is
is there a risk that he could could
offend while he's on
um bell and that's what happened here uh
so it's really uh difficult to imagine a
scenario where the district attorney or
the court
uh having been aware of a 50-page rap
sheet would set his bell
at one thousand dollars so it's going to
be interesting to see where this
investigation goes yeah that's
definitely a head scratcher i'm not a
big proponent of pre-trial uh
incarceration but this seems to be a
situation that seemed like someone
overlooked something uh terry brooks
filed a motion for change of venue but
this case has had national attention so
will he be successful
well i doubt he will be successful brian
you know change of venue is always made
when the defendant or his attorney
believes he's not going to get a fair
trial obviously under the sixth
amendment he's entitled to a fair trial
but this case got so much publicity it
really doesn't matter where he goes in
wisconsin all of those counties are
about the same size which is one of the
things the judge is going to consider
and everyone has heard of this case so
the judge will probably deny that motion
yeah we'll see how that continues as
this case develops and goes on i agree
with you terry i don't see a change of
uh venue here that would survive an
argument but we'll see and in
mississippi a father and son are charged
for chasing down and shooting at a black
fedex driver it happened on january 24th
in brookhaven mississippi 24 year old
the ontario gibson a black fedex driver
says he was delivering packages when a
pickup truck began following him after
that he says at least five shots were
fired at him officials say gregory case
drove the pickup truck that followed
gibson while his son brandon chase fired
at him the father and son were arrested
on february 1st and now face charges of
aggravated assault shooting into an
occupied vehicle and conspiracy the case
has drawn similarities to the murder of
ahmad arbury during which a white father
and son duo followed aubry in their
pickup truck 25 year old aubry a black
man was shot killed last fall gregory
and travis and michael and their
neighbor william roddy bryan were
convicted in his murder right now jury
selection is underway as all three men
face federal hate crime charges in
connection to aubry's death
this week on prime crime we take a
closer look at the state trial for
gregory and trusting michael and william
roddy bryant host jesse weber joins us
now with a look ahead to the newest
episode jesse
hey there brian yeah on our next episode
it's about the case that the whole
country had followed i'm talking about
the death of a mod arbory we start with
the infamous cell phone video capturing
the shooting of this 25 year old in
satilla shores georgia and then we move
into the body cam videos of officers
questioning the three defendants at the
crime scene and of course we break down
their murder trial including when the
shooter travis mcmichael took the stand
tune in to law and crime
thanks jesse you can catch this week's
episode of prime crime friday night at 5
30 p.m and 10 30 p.m eastern time here
on law and crime network still ahead on
law and crime daily eight years after
the crime a jury is seated in the murder
trial for an ex-florida police captain
but first
this is not fair it is unacceptable i
should not have to bury a 22 year old
child
the family of amir along calls for a ban
on no knock warrants just days after he
is shot and killed at the hands of the
police that's next on law on crime daily
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back in the wake of amir lok's
death the coming trial for brett
hankinson there is a renewed focus on
banning no knock warrants the family of
amir lok now calling for a state law
that would completely ban warrants
without knocking on thursday locke's
family and others affected by gun
violence joined famed civil rights
attorney ben crump to rally at the
minnesota state capitol this comes just
one week after 22 year old amir locke
was shot and killed when a no knock
warrant was executed body camera video
shows officers raid an apartment as
locke is sleeping on the couch with a
gun he legally owned officers fired
killing locke police were looking for
locke's cousin 17-year-old makai speed
who was since been arrested and charged
with murder locke was not named on the
warrant on thursday family members
called for a state and nationwide ban on
no knock warrants
the blood is on the legislation
amen that's the facts
the truth needs no support
we all saw what we saw
i'ma tell you this now
we demand
that they pass the law for no knock
warrants
in the name of my son amir
we demand justice
and we demand that this is done properly
and not tomorrow
not later let not later on
in two years we demand that it's done
immediately i gave birth to amir loch
in the twin cities
born and raised
and on 222
instead of y'all saying your slogan here
is minnesota nice
y'all need to change it to minnesota
lives
i am demanding
that president biden
and everybody else
from the ground up to the top
banned
no naca warrants across the united
states of america in the name of amir
ricardo
back to break down the push to end no
knock warrants as criminal defense
attorney matthew mangino and terry
austin terry taylor and locke have
become rallying cries dan no knock
warrants but what's the argument to keep
them
well look there's always two sides to
every argument basically and the
rationale for keeping these no knock
warrants is they are needed to apprehend
certain types of suspects in certain
types of situations that are dangerous
but it should really be limited and
those situations would be situations for
instance if there is a hostage involved
and the police are arguing to keep the
no knock warrants because they think
it's going to prevent
suspects from fleeing or from destroying
evidence but when you look at both sides
honestly i think banning them all
together except in hostage situations
might be the way to go here yeah i mean
because i'm seeing the danger not just
for the people who are inside the home
but also for the officers entering as
well i can't see why what others
wouldn't see the same matthew could this
be the tipping point and no knock
warrants both in minnesota and even the
country abroad
well it it may be uh you know as terry
said there there have been reasons
traditionally that we use these types of
warrants uh but i i think they should be
extremely
narrow now um
there's just too much uh possibility of
harm of innocent people and while we
hear of of amir loch and brianna taylor
there are mistakes made all the time and
fortunately they're not lethal someone
doesn't end up dead but people people's
homes are broken into
by the police with no knock warrants and
they have no idea what's going on so so
i think if we narrow this down
i don't think it's a legitimate reason
to say we need to preserve evidence to
have a no knock warrant only if there's
an extreme danger to police or as terry
said a hostage situation
should a no knock warrant be used yeah
especially in places where you are
allowed to legally own a gun it just
seems like a problem waiting to happen
but we'll follow this case as it
develops and nearly two years after the
death of brianna taylor jury selection
is underway for a former kentucky police
officer who was part of the no knock
warrant that led to her death hankinson
is the only officer facing charges
related to that raid but not a single
officer was charged in taylor's death in
march 2020 three louisville police
officers executed a no knock warrant at
taylor's apartment her boyfriend fired
at the officers believing they were
intruders when the officers fired back
taylor was shot and killed in the
crossfire hankinson faces three counts
of wanton endangerment for firing into
the apartment next at taylor's he's pled
not guilty on all three counts if
convicted he could spend up to five
years in prison opening statements are
said to be given on february 23rd the
law and crime network and i will be
there in louisville to bring you gabriel
gavel coverage
coming up on law and crime daily a jury
is chosen and an eight-year-old case is
finally going to trial what attorneys
brought to the judge as part of their
final pre-trial hearing ahead of
openings
plus attorneys make their opening
statements before a jury in a trial of
the accused daytona beach serial killer
robert hayes
[Music]
welcome back now to florida as a jury is
selected and the trial can now get
underway in the case of retired police
captain curtis reeves for shooting and
killing chad olson inside a movie
theater eight years ago reeves lawyers
maintain the former cop shot olsen in
self-defense after he confronted olsen
for being on his cell phone during the
movie's previews and popcorn was thrown
on friday attorneys spent several hours
hashing out final details at a hearing
ahead of opening statements set to begin
on monday part of the discussion focused
on what olson was using his cell phone
for during the movie previews the
prosecution argues olson was contacting
a babysitter about his daughter the
defense argues olson was looking up
racing sites and football scores defense
attorneys also talked about replaying
surveillance video and the effects of
zooming it in which can affect the
quality of the footage back in 2017 a
judge denied reeves stand your ground
argument the 79 year old now faces a
possible sentence of life in prison if
convicted criminal defense attorney
matthew mangino and co-host terry austin
are back as we look ahead to opening
statements in the florida movie theater
murder terry with opening statements set
for monday do you think the defense will
say if reeves will testify or not
well look if he does decide to testify i
would not signal that because you want
to keep your options open and
depending on whether or not he wants to
say what happened
at that scene i think that he should
probably stay off the stand he has the
right under the sixth amendment
obviously that guarantees him the right
to tell his story and especially if he
has a self-defense argument but we know
that doesn't always work out we saw it
recently in the kim potter case where it
didn't work out so i'd probably not take
a stand and not signal
i would agree with you terry based on my
own practice but i'm going to bet a
dollar that curtis reeves takes a stand
in this case and that's gonna be really
entertaining to watch matthew difference
of size even gender between aggressor
and defender can be argued in self
defense but difference of age can that
be used as well in a case like this
i think it can be brian
in uh florida you know the standard is
objective uh objective objective
reasonableness and in this situation
it's what a reasonable person would have
done in this situation so here we have a
senior citizen would a reasonable senior
citizen uh have uh used lethal force or
felt threatened to the point that he
needed to use lethal force when being
confronted here
you know i you know he as we know he
lost the stand your ground argument uh
he's gonna have a tough time with
self-defense uh but it's the only option
that's available
yeah it's gonna be an interesting
defense both with the law and the facts
we'll see how it plays out with the law
and crime network in celebrity news
netflix star jerry harris pleads guilty
this week in a federal child pornography
case harris made popular by the hit show
cheer is charged with one count of
receipt of child sexual abuse material
and one count of traveling with intent
to engage in illicit sexual conduct
according to court documents harris used
money and fame from being on cheer to
pay kids for sexual acts on snapchat and
facetime he's been in jail since
september 2020 arrest after a judge
ruled he was a significant danger to the
community but harris's lawyers now say
he wants to take responsibility for his
actions harris faces a minimum of five
years in federal prison but could face
up to 50 years behind bars should he be
given the maximum sentence on both
counts he is scheduled to be sentenced
on june 28th on top of the criminal case
against harris there is also a civil
lawsuit filed by twin brothers who say
harris sexually abused them
also in celebrity news the
self-reclaimed crocodile of wall street
and her husband were arrested on tuesday
for the alleged laundering of billions
of dollars worth of bitcoins authorities
say 31 year old heather morgan and her
husband 34 year old ilya lichtenstein
were involved in stealing 4.6 billion
dollars in bitcoin morgan is also an
amateur rapper who goes by the alias
razzle cod the stolen bitcoin is
connected to the 2016 hack of hong kong
based company bitfedex though the pair
has not been charged with the initial
hack they could be charged for alleged
conspiracy to launch a cryptocurrency
which was stolen during the hack the
judge granted bail to both morgan and
lichtenstein the couple has yet to enter
a plea if convicted they face up to 20
years in prison
when we come back we dive into the
so-called daytona beach serial killer
hear from both sides in opening
statements that's ahead on long crime
daily
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
before the first witness took the stand
friday in the anticipated trial of
accused serial killer robert hayes in
florida prosecutors and defense
attorneys had their first opportunity to
make their case before the jury hayes is
accused of killing three women laquita
gunther julie green and iwana payton
between 2005 and 2006. authorities say
they were sex workers in the daytona
beach area it wasn't until more than 10
years later when another murder happened
in west palm beach that hayes was linked
to the three killings that was a death
of rachel bay hayes is not being tried
for her death in this trial in opening
statements prosecutor told jurors hayes
admitted to using sex workers and said
his dna links them to the victims
the law enforcement wants to make sure
so they actually get a search warrant
they go to mr hayes with the search
warrant and they do the whole 23andme
swapping of the mall
and send that dna off for comparison as
well
and sure enough
hayes dna matched the male dna from
gunther as they already knew hayes dna
matched the dna recovered from
awanapatni's vagina
and hayes dna matched the dna recovered
from rachel bay's
vaginal suaves and from the top of her
left hand
ladies and gentlemen the jury
after you hear the testimony and
evidence in this case
you're going to hear from people ranging
from
late this is like somebody on the street
who didn't want to be involved with this
going to the bathroom behind a building
and finding a body you're going to hear
from multiple dna experts you're going
to hear from law enforcement from o5 law
enforcement from now
officers from multiple counties
ballistics experts you're gonna get the
chance to look and see the evidence
yourself
the audio from the courtroom is not very
clear so we're unable to play the
defense's opening statements he was very
soft-spoken hayes attorney presented an
alternative possibility of how the woman
died that another possible culprit is
responsible for the total beach death
specifically discussing a van in the
area at the time that was involved in
recruiting sex workers hayes defense
told jurors to pay attention to the
small details in this case his attorney
said if hayes dna matches what was found
on the victims that doesn't mean he
caused their deaths
matthew with no eyewitnesses to these
murders what do you think will be the
smoking gun in this trial
well you just talked about it brian it's
the dna uh you know dna was found on all
three of these victims uh
that matches um robert hayes so um you
know you might be able to argue yeah you
know he had uh
contact with these women but he really
didn't kill him but it really stretches
uh uh you know the bounds of
reasonableness that suggests that he had
contact with each of these three women
within 72 hours of them being murdered
that that isn't going to fly um i i
don't think that you get over that
hurdle
all right so matthew doesn't think it
but terry i'm going to ask you the
question uh the defense attorney
attorney's opening seems to suggest that
there
may be a connection that reeves had sex
with these women but didn't murder them
based on the concept of beyond a
reasonable doubt does that sound like
reasonable doubt to you though
yeah you know you just need that one
juror to have the reasonable doubt to
avoid a conviction i happen to agree
with matt i think there will be a
conviction here but i think it is
something the defense can argue that hey
he had sex with them but he didn't kill
them and they were prostitutes maybe
someone else did it alright we'll see
how that plays out as law and crime
covers that case thank you for joining
us here at law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you